Health experts say the triple dimmick
could jump in flu RSV and covid-19 cases
could get worse after holiday Gatherings
all these respiratory illnesses are
driving up demand for children's
medicines and some Pharmacy shelves are
now empty Carter Evans shows us how some
families are dealings dealing with the
shortage
I had to go to
for her 19 month old daughter when her
fever spiked I had myself looking in my
husband was checking in we had our
pastor looking both my parents my
siblings and nobody could could find
anything
she thinks her daughter has the flu just
one of the viruses overwhelming doctors
we never had such an amount of people
getting sick at the same time Shane
Harris just one of many parents
panicking over a run on children's pain
relief medicine at drugstores there's
nothing on the shelves it's just so
ridiculous how difficult it's been just
to get Children's Tylenol if you see
some Tylenol a profile you better grab
this is there any ended sight no we
don't know it is a shortage it's a
national shortage it's not just our
Pharmacy to combat part of the problem
the government released reserves of
Tamiflu and to prevent stockpiling CVS
Target and Walgreens are now limiting
purchases of over-the-counter Children's
Medicine what are you telling parents
that are calling you in a panic I would
say Don't Panic you know this is not
going to lead to any kind of a
complication with your child these are
medicines simply to make your child more
comfortable some parents have been using
adult medications but pediatrician Dr
Shawn O'Leary tells us parents should
follow recommended dosages compare and
substitute Adult Medicine in these cases
yes for the kids that are to swallow
pills and the dose works out properly
sure usually once kids get over 110 120
pounds that's going to match up with an
adult dose you do want to be careful in
general that you're not overdosing your
children with these medicines for CBS
warnings Carter Evans Los Angeles